Greg is um president of Reon oio uh he's
an Adjunct professor of philosophy and
Humanities at the Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design and co-host of the wisdom
for Life radio show his popular YouTube
channel has nearly 3,000 videos and has
drawn 14 million total views that's
that's very impressive Greg and we're
all going to want to know how you how
you pulled that off every wants 14
million views so we'll we'll we'll bug
you about that a little bit later he is
a member of the modern stoicism team and
edit edited stoicism today from 2016 to
2022 he recently finished the half hour
Hegel project providing line byline
commentary on the phenomenology of
spirit and to me that's even more
impressive than 14 million views on
YouTube but you can understand Hegel
that well we we want to learn more from
you about him
um after serving in the US Army as a
combat engineer Gregor to ba in
mathematics and philosophy from Lakeland
University then an Ma and PhD in
Philosophy from Southern Illinois
University at Carindale he's been a
faculty fellow at Notre Dame University
arasmus Institute a visiting scholar at
the European graduate school a Charles
Chestnut Library fellow and recently
completed the leap Institute for
nonprofit leaders
uh his Publications include a book uh
two edited volumes dozens of academic
articles book chapters and cyclopedia
entries and numerous pieces written for
popular
audiences Greg's philosophical
counseling and Consulting work focuses
on the emotions ethics leadership and
specifically on Anger Management his
past and present clients include
corporate Executives and leaders CEOs of
smaller and startup companies
psychotherapists psychologists medical
professionals professors lifelong
Learners and students welcome
Greg thanks Lou that's that's a quite an
introduction uh and actually I should
mention so the latest publication is in
the uh Journal of the AA philosophical
practice so I'm really happy about that
and it does have to do with anger
management and it comes from the uh
great conference that we had this this
uh summer thanks for inviting me for
that as well
so well you're more than welcome that
was a warm-up for this event really in a
sense and the article is of course there
now in perpetuity as long as electrons
last it'll be up there in soft copy but
it is also an article on Anger
Management of course which is one of
your Specialties so those of you who
subscribe I know that Patricia uh has
already read it you're you're always a
quick study Patrice and she's enjoyed it
so uh th those of you who have
subscribed have received it the the hard
copy is is actually at the printer so um
that will you know be be mailed out in
zo course but thank you very much both
for participating in our annual meeting
which was very successful and also for
contributing the article which we which
we much appreciate so I would like to
ask you some questions your introduction
actually poses some questions to me and
I would love to hear your responses and
then we'll open the mic
um we have we have you know in this
Agora which is intended initially the
design was really for the public um but
it turns out we have more practitioners
here than anyone but those of you who
are attending for the first time welcome
welcome to Appa Agora this is meant to
be a free public event and everybody's
welcome including of course philosophers
and we have some very experienced
practitioners in the house who who may
want to ask you questions as well so let
me go back back to some something
earlier your ba was mathematics and
philosophy what connections did you see
between I'm assuming you you explored
some connections there and what and what
was the basis of that yeah I did and
it's it's interesting when I think back
on it I I think a lot of us when we're
younger we go through phases where we
think that like there's something
that'll be like these single way to do
philosophy right for the first time and
you know there's there's others before
like dekart went through a similar phase
you know with his his early works and he
was enamored of mathematics and
everything can be mathematized and I
it's good to like go through phases like
that and thoroughly Plum that to be able
to see that it doesn't work right
there's stuff that cannot be Quantified
or dealt with using um mathematical
models you know there's paradoxes that
arise and you know so they were they
were too track that worked well together
at the place where I was because the
logic class counted as a math class and
it's not as if the math and the
philosophy professors were hostile to
each other which you might find at at
some places or they might just not
engage each other it was a small school
and you know actually if you don't mind
I'll indulging me for just one second
I'll tell you a story about why I became
a math major in the first place so you
know like I imagine many of you when you
took mathematics in middle school and
high school it was presented in kind of
a boring way you know I hated our
geometry class which was just just
mind-numbingly boring and I was one of
those kids who was good at math but I'd
be like what am I ever going to do with
this right and so I I actually you know
was a combat engineer there's there's
mathematics involved in Demolition and I
found that really fun but it was kind of
low-level stuff um and then I got into
college and I declared a philosophy
major right away because my mom's
boyfriend had said um hey declare a
major then you're not just Joe freshman
you're not going to get lost you're
you're in with a group and I thought
philosophy sounded cool and so I I did
that but the person who was putting me
into classes put me into calculus one
and I was like ah this is gonna be
terrible I mean I know I'm good at math
but I I'm this is going to be boring
just like all my other math classes have
bet
and we started out the very first day
the guy who taught it was super into
Theory so he said okay so calculus is
based on the theory of limits here's
some he doesn't he doesn't say here's
some metaphysics but here's the idea
behind it and then he goes and he starts
you know doing things on the board and I
was like this is mathematics no this is
this is more like philosophy this is
really interesting stuff so I went up to
him after class and asked him some
questions and he was totally happy
because students didn't ask him
questions about this sort of thing they
just wanted to know what the proper
techniques are and all that and so his
eyes lit up and and we start talking
about infinity and whether positive
infinity and negative Infinity like
coincide and you know so I'm really
getting into it and and if I hadn't had
that sort of Person coming along at the
right time maybe I wouldn't have majored
in mathematics because the way I ended
up doing it was I took Cal one and then
I was like yeah this is good I'll take
Cal 2 and then you've got a couple more
classes then you're like well
maybe I should minor in this maybe I
should major in this and so you you know
it's like a gateway drug you could say
and so um I I wound up you know being
interested in like the foundations of
mathematics and what logic could be used
for how we could model things you know
what what the um limitations of what we
call formal systems actually are and so
it was good to go through that um and to
get get past it I would say you know and
to become aware of the limitations of
whatever it is that we're going to base
primarily on mathematics so you know I'm
I'm not a skeptic about the use of
statistics for example in argumentation
but you know I want to if I see somebody
making a claim I want to know okay
what's your sample where did you get it
from what questions did you ask all all
those sorts of things you know so I I
found it very useful um I I actually
considered going on to graduate school
in mathematics instead of doing
philosophy but I liked philosophy better
so that's how I ended up going the route
that I went I also considered doing the
Actuarial exams which would have been at
that time a a great idea because actuary
was um considered one of the best
professions you could do in terms of
stress money all that kind of stuff but
now the actuaries are getting phased out
by AI so maybe it wouldn't have been
such a great idea to do right right well
our turn will come no doubt I I'm I'm
I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop
Greg and we're gonna for philosophers
yeah well as soon as AI gets good enough
to uh you know to compete with some of
our professors and it's probably getting
close in some cases they uh uh
University administrators will not be
slow to replace us I'm quite sure I'm
saying this to your tongue and cheek
what you probably don't know um and I'm
sure a lot of the of our of our
participants don't know that I also did
a degree in mathematics
I didn't know that no I know that's why
I'm telling you we've been on the same
page there for quite a while and this
goes back to Plato and Pythagoras you
know there are ancient roots for this
the the harmony of the universe the
vibrations of the universe all these
fundamental metaphysical Concepts really
get tricked out that way but I love
geometry and I got tired of solving
differential equations at some point I
was doing a um you know an MA in in
mathematical physics and that's all it
was it was just solving yeah the power
of solving problems is a great thing and
then the idea is how do we transpose
problem solving into these value Laten
spaces right that's the real art for us
so it's great that you basically got
this very rigorous foundation and that
you've been able to build so much on it
yeah it's interesting you know when you
think about value there's a lot of
people who want to reduce value down to
something that could be
Quantified and I mean in some respects
you can do that like with cost benefit
analysis and business ethics there's
certain things that you can do that with
and you got to kind of make up values
like what's a human life worth what's
what's the loss of a limb worth you know
it's always a little ad hoc but then
there's all these other things where um
a quantitative approach to it is just
not going to work where you know we need
something that's more based in the
humanities and and what that offers you
know well absolutely and so let me ask
you this though you you were also a
combat engineer in the US Army more
problem solving and a very practical Co
did the Army train you in
engineering not in what what we normally
think of as engineering so combat
engineers think of them as one step up
from
infantry and given a lot more um tools
and and technology and smaller groups
and and they're expected to go out in
front of the other troops and do things
like lay Mine Fields blow up obstacles
put up you know fences and you know
maybe make bridges or things like that
so it's a combat arms thing and and I
hope I don't offend anybody by saying
this but this is actually quite true
combat arms people in in the military
not usually the brightest Bunch you know
I if if you can't qualify to be
something like Finance or Supply or
something then they put you in INF
infantry or armor or artillery so so
actually you do learn a lot of problem
solving matters in how to get people who
are not particularly bright or motivated
to get things done you know um it it was
it was a lot of fun in in many respects
you know blowing things up pretending to
go out on on uh training exercises and
stuff like that but there were a lot of
things where you're like how did
somebody like how could they be so
thoughtless as to do this or this or
this right and so learning how to deal
with that sort of stuff without letting
it get you all upset um that was that
was quite helpful in terms of life
lessons and I will say this too I had no
intention of ever going to college and
if I had gone to college straight out of
high school I probably would have like
flunked out because I would have been
partying and not taking it
seriously um I actually in in high
school I at graduation
was called up to receive a special award
and uh when it got handed to me it was
kind of a backhanded compliment it was
for succeeding despite the odds it was
like a little plaque and a law firm in
town had set aside $700 I guess every
year for this sort of thing so they
handed it to me and I spent it on uh
tuition for my karate school that I was
going to at the time and then I sent
them a letter saying I'm not going to
college I'm just working in a restaurant
doing that and then I went in the Army
and the Army gave me you know some
discipline and capacity for like
learning how to deal with other people's
nonsense and so then when I went to
college um I was able to do pretty good
you know but if I if I hadn't gone
through that I I probably would be still
working in restaurants today you know
yes and part of our attrition rate and a
lot of people aren't working in
restaurants anymore post pandemic but uh
you know our attrition rate um in the US
is higher than it would be if people did
especially the boys I would say because
they mature more slowly if at all but
but they generally at age 18 are not are
not mature enough come out of high
school and Tackle University curriculum
and there are plenty of European
countries that compel them to do
military service whether these countries
are actually involved in ongoing
conflict or not Greece does Finland does
I think Norway might still do it Israel
obviously but the thing is that what
they find empirically and which won't
surprise you or or me but they they are
much more serious at 22 than they were
at 18 and they're much better equipped
to handle a a a and complete a college
curriculum at that
stage yeah I mean even if they even if
you didn't do something military
oriented and you did did just like work
in restaurants or in some other you
know some other Enterprise you're
probably going to be by the time that
you're 22 hopefully better better
equipped to handle um what's involved in
in college education and it is kind of a
shame that we we push it so hard you
know oh you've got to go to college you
got to go to college that's the only way
to to succeed because I you know I I
don't know about you but in some of the
places where I've taught that are fed by
college prep schools a lot of these kids
get there and you know they're they're
smart they're courteous they're they're
diligent but they seem kind of lost and
they've picked a major that they're not
really that interested in studying
because they heard it would be good for
them you know and it's it's usually like
business uh one of the ones under that
or Communications or psychology or
something along those lines you know
sure well you know the iron law of the
Invisible Hand kicks in at some point as
well in the UK they have never been
ashamed of what they call Red Brick
polytechnics where people who really
weren't cut out necessarily for an
aidite kind of scholar career could
still learn some very valuable skills
that would benefit themselves in society
and there was no shame at all involved
in it and we are coming around in
America to rediscovering that we need
more skilled trades people than ever
before and so the equivalent is is what
we call Vocational School basically but
these these trades never uh become
extinct and in fact the economy now
dictates that we have a shortage of them
so I think that this kind of vacuum is
bound to be filled uh but also there's
something to be said about the slower
maturation process you know
mathematicians and philosophers tend to
have two very creative periods one early
in their even late teens and early 20s
where they get phenomenal work done if
they if that bents and then there can be
a a sort of a Hiatus and then they can
come back in their 50s uh were even
later had of another burst of of of
lasting creativity and and contribution
so that that makes sort of sense you
know that you went through this what was
your graduate work when you finally did
go for the as we call it the Trade union
card you know the PHD what what was your
thesis about what did you talk oh you
know um I took a year off in between
undergrad and graduate school because I
was kind of I had what they called
senioritis at the time and and they
still use that term now where I was just
kind of burnt out and I I worked for a
living I lived here in Milwaukee and
worked as a security guard which was
great because that third shift I could
do a lot of reading and I got a lot of
exercise done and I worked as a barista
and then I I you know I had no idea I'm
essentially first generation College
because although my my dad was a tax
attorney he' gone to W Madison he died
when I was 11 and most of my family are
trades people so nobody could give you
any useful advice right so I didn't have
any idea about where you should apply to
or stuff like that so I just sent out
applications and Southern Illinois got
to me the quickest with uh the most
money and I was like yeah sounds good
I'll go down there you know and it was a
great department at the time
unfortunately due to the budget cutbacks
in in Illinois since the financial
crisis uh the the department has just
gutted it was about 14 professors
full-time when I was there and it's down
to four full-time people which is not
enough to sustain a a a graduate program
I think and so I think they'll probably
end up closing that and it was nicely
distributed there were analytic
philosophers there were Continental
philosophers there were it was also a
place that had a great strength in
classical American philosophy and then
there were a few history of philosophy
people and if you wanted to do more um
you know classic stuff there was a
Classics department where you could
study Greek and you could do your
rhetoric with the English Department or
speech Communications and stuff like
that so so I I took as many classes as
they would let me and I I did my
Master's thesis on
huso um one of the professors was
translating the passive synthesis
lectures at the time and so I did that
and I brought in you know stuff about
language from dis soer and all that and
ended up basically just duplicating what
dared da had done in speech and
phenomena because I hadn't read that
book so that was kind of valueless as
far as like publishing anything because
it had already been done but it was it
was a good practice for me and then for
my
dissertation um I was originally gonna
write on Hegel and this guy Maurice
Blondell who's often called the French
or the Catholic Hegel dialectical
philosopher and my committee said that's
a little bit too ambitious why don't you
just write on Blondell you really like
the guy nobody else writes on him so I
did and I wound up with this sprawling
thing that I never ended up um doing
more than publishing a little you know
section of um I would say that a lot of
my mentoring was essentially benign
neglect they would say ah you seem like
you know what you're doing just keep
going that route you know and it was
good for me because I would read
whatever I wanted I had facility with
languages so I could you know go back to
original texts and I would I would work
on stuff that other people considered um
not trendy enough you know but I thought
was interesting but you know as a career
move not not a great idea right so but
how did you get attracted to
phenomenology I mean you you were you
know you're doing hardcore mathematics
and uh well you know where I was an
undergrad and again funny story right
our philosophy professors were
essentially way past their Prime and
they hadn't kept up on any contemporary
literature so they thought
that there were basically four main
important movements in philosophy going
on at the time one of which was analytic
philosophy which they thought was going
to die out in a couple decades or so
clearly wrong they thought Marxism was
important May was at the time right um
still in the early 90s and then uh
existentialism which overlaps
considerably with phenomenology and then
process philosophy so that's what they
kind of put forward is like this is this
is The Cutting Edge stuff and if if it
wasn't for having like friends who
actually read more contemporary stuff I
probably would have been really left
behind you so you know I get through the
existentialism stuff I got introduced to
phenomenology and then you know you get
to grad school and you take graduate
level classes and so the guy Anthony
Steinbach who I think he's back in in
Sunni now somewhere he um he was the one
who was translating the passive
synthesis
stuff he was a whal scholar and we took
a class on it and I was like yeah I
could do something with this although
actually now that I now that I remember
it I was originally trying to do my
Master's thesis on wienstein
and there was a great wienstein scholar
there uh Donna Summerfield who she you
know was pretty well known in the field
and she'd studied with people who'd
studied with wienstein she unfortunately
died quite young of cancer um cutting
her career you know uh short like
in in middle
age and I couldn't get her to quite
understand what it was that I was trying
to do with wienstein she'd just give me
this like blank look and say I I just
don't understand what you're saying and
I was interested in this question about
like well you know vicenin has this
notion of language games and forms of
life what is the nature of language
games that we can conceptualize this
notion of language games within it so
it's a recursive problem right and she
would just like stare give me this blank
there and and maybe I wasn't explaining
it well enough or maybe she just had a
block or something so I abandoned it and
then wrote on Hil instead you know so he
had to write on something right well yes
but again very surprising choices given
that you're you're from sounds like
mainstream uh American tradition Madison
by the way is a fabulous town I I don't
know if our many of our participants
know of it or have been there I've been
to Madison and they had a a they had a
wonderful NPR one of the best nprs was
out of there as you know and also there
there they told me when I arrived in
Madison for a visit that by Statute the
University was built within a very short
distance of the legislature I think it's
within five miles and there there was a
law in Wisconsin that the government
would never be more than a certain
distance from the so-called Brain Trust
of the state and I thought that was
quite enlightened of them it's nothing
like New York you know we have our
capital in Albany they couldn't be
further from Manhattan unless Buffalo
but seriously this signaled some kind of
a sobriety that was quite surprising and
uplifting well we have we have two
interesting Traditions here in Wisconsin
that unfortunately have kind of Fallen
by the
wayside um you know it was originally
one of the hardcore abolitionist Estates
um there's you one of our Governors
Randall Alexander actually threatened at
the time of um Lincoln's election that
if Lincoln wasn't elected he was going
to withdraw Wisconsin from the union so
um what do they call that you know
withdrawing the
state secession secession yeah it wasn't
just a southern thing it was also a
northern thing but it was because they
didn't want to collaborate with the you
know slave ocracy which was viewed as
dominating um unfortunately at that time
the the you know United States um so
we've got that long you know tradition
of equality and and we also um in
significant part because of the German
Heritage it wasn't just any old German
Heritage it was Germans who fled after
the failed Revolutions in
1848 we had a strong socialist um uh
strain to Wisconsin politics and it you
know it plays out in things like for
example in the city of
Milwaukee compared to Chicago per capita
we have four times as much green space
as they do because it was felt that you
know poor people deserve to experience
nature in the dirty City and so we
needed lots and lots of parks you know
and so there's all sorts of aspects like
that of Wisconsin and so it doesn't
surprise me that there was this yeah the
the legislature we got to keep an eye on
those guys you know they need to be
accessible to the rest of us this sort
of
egalitarianism and uh thinking about
large larger society
unfortunately not as big a part of
Wisconsin politics now as it it used to
be but yeah sure well you know uh the
older we get the better we used to be
you know that
say might have Collective applications
but another impressive thing and then
we'll get back to philosophy but I've
always been a fan of the Green Bay
Packers and uh uh you know my father was
a great football fan he loved the
Packers he loved that Vince Lombard he
wanted to go to a place which had a
losing record and forg them into winners
he did not want to take over a winning
team he wanted to take a team from the
bottom to the top which he did with his
pH football which is also a philosophy
of life I mean he was a remarkable man
but the not notable thing and I don't
know if it's still true is that the
Green Bay Packers were the only NFL team
that was publicly owned right I mean
they're not it's not a private owner
every we own stocking them some oligarch
you know an oligarch with a with a with
a whole bunch of teams on the string but
Green Bay it's public isn't it it is
although your Packer stock doesn't you
you pay about I think we paid $250 a
share and it entitles you to like go to
meetings and stuff like that but not
much more more than that where the real
action is is season tickets you know
which uh you get into this this pool
like we are expected we we applied for
it when we first got here it's expected
another eight years we should be able to
purchase season tickets because they're
so highly sought after but there is this
ethos um it's interesting with the
Packers everywhere that we've gone
during during the season if like we're
at a conference there is a Packer bar
somewhere so like in New York City it's
kettle of fish and you can go there and
my wife has she's been to that I've been
to ones in Boston and other places and
the Curious thing is you get all these
New Yorkers and they come in you know
and they're they're often dressed quite
nicely and as the game is beginning
they're talking with the kind of typical
New York accent right that they've
picked up and then by halftime they're
they're with the Wisconsin y hay sort of
accent oh yeah look at that uh you know
they're eating cheese curds and all that
sort of stuff you know so but but it is
interesting that um you can go just
about anywhere and there are going to be
some some people who you can relate to
um as as fans and sometimes you actually
have to get like reserv because the the
bars will be so so packed when they're
winning you know now pretty easy because
they're they're not having a great
season but well they've had plenty for
and for for a small community relative
to the larger cities that you know
football teams it's really incredible I
think the tradition that carries on um
and and for again for our audience if
you're ever in Chicago and have a day or
two it's a pretty short drive to Madison
milwauke is a little further as you know
but it's it's about the same it's about
the same well I went to Madison from
from Ohara it was it was a short drive
yeah um hour maybe hour and a half
whatever it was couple of hours at the
most so it's easy to reach if you're in
the Midwest and uh definitely
recommended to spend some time there
it's very interesting place so Greg how
did you move from all of this into
philosophical practice was it sudden was
it gradual how how did you become a
practitioner of philosophy so I was
doing some of the things that we we call
philosophical practice on kind of an ad
hoc basis with uh colleagues
before I went through you know the
training and certification that I think
it was
2014 um the summer that that uh you you
you led that um uh down in in New York
City and uh I don't know if it's my wife
who came across it first or if I came
across it but I was likew you know I'm
already doing stuff like this and not
getting paid for it at all um and you
know I could probably do it better and
up my game if I connect up with other
people who are doing this and have like
you know a body of practice associated
with it right so it's not just me kind
of making it up as I go
along and uh that's that's what drew me
to to do the the certification which was
very useful um uh and I I I I will say
this and this gonna sound like I'm
making a pitch for it um so you know the
reading beforeand in preparation and
then the discussion of like well what is
philosophical practice how do you do it
that that's very useful but then the
Hands-On stuff like well how do you
actually establish a business you need
insurance you know where are you going
to get your clients from how do you set
your rates that those sort of nuts and
bolts things very useful as well and I
don't think that I would have come up
and maybe I would have come up with that
but it probably would have taken me
years and I probably wouldn't have done
it as well without you know
participating in those discussions uh
informed by by you and vanana and other
people who'd been doing it for for
decades so yeah but great but you know
this is a uh a profession if it is a
profession I think it is um a profession
without State recognition is probably a
good thing we don't we don't want
governments regulating philosophy not a
good idea but but nonetheless it's a a
population of of of really
self-identifying practitioners you know
people who've always in one way or
another either thought about it or have
done it and again there's no need to
reinvent the wheels we didn't reinvent
all the wheels either but we as you well
know and we're preaching to the choir
here because Mo most of the I'm looking
at the at the participant list and there
are so many who've been through our
program and some of you who have not yet
I hope you will but the point is um that
we we had to uh blaz some Trails you
know in order to turn for they don't
teach this practical stuff in graduate
school nor should they necessarily but
it still has to be a threshold that gets
crossed at some point when you step out
of the academy you you you have to have
some trappings and semblance of what it
means to be a professional outside the
academy that's necessary yeah I think
that that's quite true I mean I know
that having the certification has opened
doors because people will be like well
so what exactly are you are you a
consultant are you a life coach you can
be no I'm a philosophical practitioner
here's here's what we did and then they
can wrap their head around it whereas if
I were just to like try to invent it all
on my own I don't think it would have
worked as as well um and it's
interesting too you know I I'd be
curious to hear um from you about this
or any of the other people that that
want to chime in about this so you do
get push back from from colleagues who
when they find out that you do this kind
of work they don't they don't like that
they're like you're debasing philosophy
you're one to actually use the word
prostituting at one point um and I I
actually had a chair of a local
philosophy Department I won't say which
one it is because I don't want anyone
like looking them up I'll just say that
they're since retired who came up to me
at a local conference and I'd never
talked to this person in my life and he
came up to me and he said you know what
you do isn't really philosophy and then
he just turned around and walked away
and I was like
what and uh so there's there's some
resentment that I think it it provokes
among traditional academic philosophers
and maybe that's based in fear maybe
that's based in um you know worries
about you know popularizing things but I
I mean you've been doing this for for
decades and decades I imagine the
resistance to it must have been a lot
stronger earlier on is that is that
right certainly we we had but exactly
the same kind of pushback that that
anybody would expect to get uh
externally from Mostly the psychologist
psychiatrists you know are not so
opposed to this um because Psychiatry of
course is studying the organ that we
think is you know the place we live in
so so they they are the most Phil you
know the most philosophical of the
Medical Specialties obviously and and
many of them are including people like
irin yellow you know I've developed a
friendship with him over the years and
he's very philosophical in fact I think
he's a wannabe philosopher if you look
at the novels he's written about Spinosa
and and N uh you know and schopenhauer
it's obvious that he has some affinity
for these thinkers even though he's busy
trying to diagnose them as either mental
eel or something else that's a
psychiatric training but he's not an
enemy of philosophy at all whereas too
many psych many many of our
psychologists within apaa are of course
understanding of the origins of
psychology which our philosophy and so
they just want to get closer to the
source and they're our friends and
allies but initially there was a lot of
push back um and it's not to be taken
personally because as I learned uh from
some law firms that helped us navigate
these Waters um the psychology
profession pushes back against a lot of
initiatives that might look like they're
poaching or encroaching on their Turf
they want to monopolize the psyche as
far as they're able they have the power
of lenser and they proactively will
interfere with and shut down anything
that looks like a threat that's
unfortunate but it's a Turf War there
are rivers of money look this is America
there are rivers of money flowing into
the you know into into the Health Care
system and anyone who looks like they're
going to fish in that in in that
tributary will will be subject to the
push back from psychology primarily but
also internally we've all experience
what you have primarily from the
analytic
philosophers not So Much from the
applied ethicists not So Much from the
activist branches of
philosophy but the pure analytic
tradition believe makes a fundamental
mistake of of regarding the part as the
whole that they think that theoretical
philosophy is all there is and all there
should be so there is this ran ma or
fear or anxiety of the unknown when they
see and so the accusation you use the
word Greg popularizer they use it as a
pejorative they used to but then you
have phenomenally successful people who
actually are helping them by
popularizing philosophy we attract more
students into philosophy departments and
this benefits the analytic types whether
they realize it or not we're actually
helping them too you know I have I this
is a bit of a digression but I have a
short theory about like philosophy and
justifying itself that I'd like to run
past you because it's drawn on my like
personal impressions of what happened in
the the 70s and 80s and obviously I was
you know too young to like be seeing
what was happening in the field but I
kind of got the idea that a lot of
philosophy departments you know there
was plenty of money flowing to
Universities at that time whether
they're state or or private or whatever
and so philosophy departments and the
kind of things that they they were
willing to consider philosophy they
could be elitist about it they could be
like you know philosophy is for really
smart people you're not really smart
enough why don't you go over there to
psychology or business or you know one
of these other fields you know the kind
of stuff that we do you wouldn't get it
you and you look at this a lot of the
stuff that was was being published at
the time and it's kind of along those
lines there I remember getting a book at
a used bookstore and it was called what
philosophy can do and the guy was making
a case at basically conceptual analysis
and all the rest of it is nonsense you
know that's what philosophers should be
focused on and that works fine so long
as the money is flowing through right
but as soon as you have to like make a
case to people who are going to write
your checks who aren't you know they
haven't taken philosophy classes you'd
better be able to explain what it is
that you're doing first of all and then
what sort of positive impact you're
having and I think that's one reason why
it became easy to cut um departments and
you know uh reduce budgets sometimes
close departments uh because there was
this perception that philosophy doesn't
really do anything it's just kind of
sitting around and pontificating and
it's essentially waste of time um and
you know was somebody who's kind of you
know from an ordinary background I mean
I can see that I don't I don't pay for
services that I don't use so why would
they want if if we can't give a
justification of how we're benefiting
people um through what we're teaching
and how we're teaching them why why
should they pay for us you know so but
was it was it like that in the 70s and
80s that the sort of it was good for a
long time yeah because philosophy was
regarded as even if it were useless
ultimately or application lless
ultimately it was regarded as a kind of
mental gymnastic that at least could
help people develop rigorous thinking
waving and other things so you know
there was some but the analytics School
in particular did such a good job of
making itself irrelevant and
inaccessible that they are now paying
the price when when when Humanities is
being defunded part of it is a broader
ignorance on the part of the
administrative class you know
unfortunately and hubris uh we need stem
but but we're losing what it means to be
human because of the defunding of
humanities it's a great tragedy so
philosophy becomes more important in the
end and just as we are self- selecting
and all the practitioners in Appo are
people who are self- selecting they they
they had visions of themselves and we're
are already practicing before APPA was
formed and we just find that as an
organization we have more credibility we
have more support you know we have more
strength obviously there are still
Independents out there who do well but
just as that's happening our clientel is
self- selecting too people are not as
dumb as often they're characterized as
being and there are a lot of people who
who have looked at what's on offer to
them and have realized it's not enough
it may be necessary at a given time to
have a medical or psychological or
psychiatric intervention or a legal one
for that matter but it's not enough
there's something else in life and when
people encounter that moments when they
actually need a philosopher they
suddenly become very grateful that we're
there yeah I I think one of the things
that comes out in what you're saying is
like Ordinary People okay some of them
are pretty dumb but there's plenty of
like you know Elite people who are
pretty dumb too in the sense of like
they can't manage their life and they
make silly decisions and they don't have
good good bases for it but most people
tend to be smarter than uh academics
give them credit for I think and and
part of the problem is we we wind up
setting up this divide you know and they
feel like some how are they going to get
across it to to access the things that
you know we academics or we Elite or
whatever you want to say have to to
offer them um and it is kind of cool
with the internet you know it's really
it hasn't completely changed everything
the way that early adopters were wanting
to say oh we're going to live in a
totally different time you know a
different era
because you know we're still doing a lot
of the same stuff right but um it
democratized access to
information in really massively
important ways so you know if you wanted
to know something about say Aristotle in
the
past it could actually be quite quite
tough you know if you didn't have a good
library near you you didn't know what to
access I mean now you can just you can
go on you can find great encyclopedia
articles you can find entire free texts
you can find all sorts of resources
videos podcasts you can find um people
who aren't working in Academia who are
interested say in Aristotle's rhetoric
or Aristotle's uh Nic McCain ethics and
how it would apply to to life and
they'll do a podcast on it and you can
listen to it and maybe they're not
getting things 100% right but they don't
have to you know you can you can advance
uh in in dialectically engaging them and
saying well here's where where I think
it's wrong you know um and so it's we we
we're really living in an extraordinary
era I think for the the possibilities of
ordinary people getting access to these
what were typically you know really
Elite products you know well two two
questions for you before I open the mic
you know yeah just one comment remember
Vicken Stein also talks about a
disordering of the concepts and a lot of
our clients not withstanding the vast uh
Seas of information in which we're all
drowning they don't necessarily have a
library catalog or its equivalent that
helps them to with a taxonomy where
where does all the how do how do we sort
this data what is important what is true
what is false we encounter all these
problems all over again so having a good
conceptual framework I think really
abets a more efficient and optimal use
of the vast amounts of data available to
everybody and that's where we play a
role that nobody else plays in helping
people to get a handle on ordering their
Concepts and on clarifying their con so
so with that you know I want to ask you
two questions first of all I guess what
everybody wants to know how do you get
14 million views on your YouTube channel
and secondly could you give us an
example of a of a kind of case that you
think is is in some way um exemplary of
your own kind of practice be it a CEO
client or be it a psychology client or
be it whoever you like just give us just
give us a quick case study from your own
practice and then tell us how you became
so phenomenally popular on on you know
on on YouTube that's really interesting
well I will say this there there are
channels out there that make mine look
like you know a little tiny dwarf in
comparison you know um they're not
necessarily always great some of them
are pretty pretty good some of them are
if you make your stuff really high
production and the videos are short and
you don't go too deep you're going to
get way more views right especially if
you're like to court controversy you're
like can you believe what Aristotle said
you know that that sort of approach so
you know there's there's famous famous
and then there's YouTube famous right
and YouTube famous is sort of like you
know a little bit lower or actually a
lot lower than being actually famous um
now the 14 million views so I've been
doing YouTube videos for 12 years I
think at this point and um you know it
it it increased
exponentially um at first the first
maybe two three years I didn't have as
many videos out I wasn't getting quite
as many views but it it takes off after
a while and I I projected a consistent
ethos which I think is based in
something real that I'm not g to
anybody I'm not gonna like you
know talk about the popular topic of the
day just because it's popular I'm just
going to give you the Straight Dope as
far as I understand it on these thinkers
or texts that I'm I'm teaching about and
I'm not I'm not overly critical so like
when I teach somebody I don't
fundamentally agree with like Kant or
Hume I present it you know I I present
it
sympathetically without um saying oh and
here's where Kant is wrong about this
you know I just I present it um
charitably and so people know that they
can go to me for accurate competent
exposition of stuff that I'm not going
to spend a lot of time you know putting
Graphics in or you know making beautiful
sound stuff it's going to just be like
classroom teaching so that that appealed
to people and it's interesting because
when I first started I don't know if I
ever told you this but I'm I'm kind of
I'm not politically conservative but I'm
temperamentally conservative I don't
like a lot of change and I'm very
suspicious of you know proposals to do
big projects so my wife wife is the
early adopter you know let's do this
this cool thing sort of big picture kind
of planner and she was the one who
convinced me to put videos
online she was like she got me a flip
Cam and she's like why don't you record
your classroom sessions and I was like
well Who the hell's going to want to
watch me I'm nobody you know uh and you
know the lighting isn't good and the
sound isn't good and she's like what do
you have to lose just try it out and I
was like well okay I guess I'll it right
and I did that first at fville State
University just with these critical
thinking classes which which they own
because at that time YouTube you
couldn't upload more than like 10
minutes at a time so we had to do it
institutionally and you know the biggest
Catalyst for me was the comments that I
got because there were there were people
who were saying thanks for putting this
out there my professor won't explain
anything and I was going to like you
know flunk the class and this or that or
I used to go to college this is really
nice it's like being in college again or
I can't afford to go to college thanks
for putting these resources out there so
that told me that there was this you
know big vast pool of people who are
hungry for it doesn't even to be like
perfect just decently presented
competently thought out information
about philosophy and what's your optimal
length not too long as you say Too Short
what what you want meet in there right
yeah it really depends on what you're
trying to do so it's interesting too
because the educational experts when I
was so I was starting out on the 2010s
and the educational experts were all
convinced that a video cannot be longer
than 5 minutes because these students
their attention span is so short they
won't watch anything and I and they were
also saying oh you can't just do talk
and talk you know and that's exactly
what I did so I put like you know um a a
whole class session out there and people
would watch the whole thing you know so
the educational experts didn't know what
they were talking about or they hadn't
done enough sampling right and I found
that
um some things I I like to do these what
we call Core concept videos where
they're anywhere from like 10 to 20
minutes long and I'll take like a whole
text like I'm working through K proma to
any future metaphysics right now and
each main idea I'll spend that amount of
time and I put stuff on the chalkboard
and I get up and I I talk about that so
to finish that text we're talking like
maybe 35 40 videos you know um and
people will watch them some people will
skip through it to find just the the
stuff that they want although I think
that's kind of tough to do but then I'll
do other videos that are two hours long
and people will watch those if if
they're interested you know like I do
these uh videos about um speculative
fiction series and they're supposed to
end at 90 minutes but often they wind up
being two hours and if if your you know
if your content is interesting enough
people will will watch it and uh you
know like what we're doing here this
will this will be a video that I think
people will watch probably in its
entirety because they want to see what's
happening next right well let's see
what's happening what's happening next
is just before I open the mic um please
give us a quick thumbnail of one of your
a case yeah let's hear about a
case yeah so you know one of the cases
that I've been thinking a lot about and
I I haven't I I should start doing this
writing case studies yes um the journal
because we want to public but give us
give us a little sampler please so I had
a guy and I think there's lots of people
out there like this who came to me and
he was uh he was very upset because he
had been listening to Sam Harris's
podcast and um Sam Harris is you know
kind of a skeptic about Free Will and
and all of that and this guy was um H
having some serious emotional
difficulties because he was like well
what if Sam Harris is actually right
about this then I'm basically just a
mechanism I think I have free will but
I'm clearly diluted and all that and it
it took a couple sessions but the gist
of what I did with him was say well why
why do you think Sam Harris is correct
about this I mean how did he possibly
sample enough people to figure out that
there couldn't possibly be any free
choices out there this is a rather
dogmatic assertion and so um it's it's
you know it falls within that that scope
of of of philosophical practice
examining
assumptions and seeing where people are
um you know engaging ing in mistaken
lines of reasoning which then lead
to really traumatic um emotional results
right and it was kind of like at at at
after a couple sessions it took like I
think three
sessions um you could see like that kind
of proverbial light bulb go off and he's
like yeah holy crap why am I actually
giving these people such Credence on
these massively sweeping metaphysical
claims when I don't know where the hell
they're getting this from you know and
and you know this this happens a lot
with Neuroscience people I I I like to
say that
Neuroscience um because I'm not
dismissing it includes everything from
really rigorous science to total
quackery and pseudo science and
everything in between because there's a
lot of people who think that well we'll
just do some brain scans on 10
Volunteers in a university setting in a
very artificial experiment and then
we'll deduce some pretty massive things
about the human emotions or
decision-making processes and you're
like well this is terrible philosophy
really you know I mean so anyway I I
worked with him on that and and you know
sometimes you gota and I'd be interested
to see what what you have to say about
this sometimes you gotta kind of like
you can't approach the the problem
directly and say Here's your problem
buddy you know let's just do this and it
works you got to kind of pick here and
pick here and and you know kind of it's
almost like unraveling a not you know
it's dialogue this is what dialogue does
it unravels the not for the client too
but I I'm I'm remembering Isaac bashevis
Singer's response to this which is not
resolving anything but it's amusing and
he he noted once that every time he
crosses the street with a fatalist he
says the fatalist always waits for the
light to change
so just a humorous observation about
hard determinism yeah okay with that I'd
like to open the floor and please um
show your hands uh physically I can't
see everyone we have PE lots of folks in
the room but if you'd like to raise your
electronic hand be happy to acknowledge
you um and then you can engage with Greg
okay please go ahead
um anyone Patricia okay go ahead
Patricia please go
ahead yes thank you Gregory I really uh
enjoyed a lot listening to you I I I did
it as well when you presented your
speech in the EPA annual meeting but of
course and and you see you are um such a
great example because uh your path is so
erogenous you pass from that that really
it's it's contemporary and and it's a
model it's a model I mean it should be
like that philosophy now should be like
this erogenous coming from different
different different experience at the
first at the first uh degree at first
basis and then and then becoming
philosophy because my personal opinion
now I'm I'm developing this during my my
year experience is that every
discipline in the end in the end becomes
philosophy so you started from
mathematics and physic like epicos or or
or Galileo and then you arrive to
philosophy and then you arrive to to to
the show because you are uh speaking to
people Unknown People through technology
through internet and so you are also a
showman a showman then speaks about
philosophy and I appreciate that a lot
and then another thing that I was
thinking listening to you was then I
always thought that to have the courage
to go in YouTube and to show yourself in
a video uh knowing that many people are
listening to you you um in a way yes you
have the responsibility to to have a
competence of course to be honest like
you are sort of
theological uh principle you are honest
and you are describing K or Hegel or
whatever in a very honest and simple way
and uh respecting the length of the
video and that's it but I always thought
that you need also to have a kind of
three theatrical you have to be trained
in theater as well in communication I
mean you have to be
you see a sort of ability to be
theatrical study theater could be useful
but then you said no because you started
just like a video camera with your wife
and then it was a success so no rule at
all I mean you can be a very theatrical
man or you can be a sort of shy
professor of philosophy and being
successful just reading perfectly I
don't know Hegel or the phenomenology of
spirit or or can or vonstein or M
and you can be successful as well
because maybe the word is so wide that
you every Everybody of us can find
little Target that even if you are very
shy or very extroverted and and
communicative I think that if you are
honest in the content in in what you say
and what you think you you put together
intellect and reason in a way body and
mind no and you I think that people can
can appreciate this so thanks a lot this
is my welcome my my yes my big thank so
there's there's a lot of uh really
interesting ideas there to respond to
and I I so I'm gonna sort of work my way
backwards it's more common than a
question actually but but yeah but it's
it's it's great stuff for uh
springboarding off of so yeah I didn't I
didn't study theater although
interestingly my my my oldest child is a
is a theater major finishing up her four
fourth year here she wanted to be
musical theater because she was very
good at singing but um she ended up
having to switch to straight theater
because musical theater involves a lot
of dancing and she has an old ballet
injury that interfered with that um but
I've I've you know my Approach um was
developed in part by years and years of
teaching what we call service classes
which are you know introduction to
philosophy ethics
the things that are for
undergraduates where they're not majors
and often times they have no idea why
the hell they're in the class or what
what good this is POS possibly gonna be
to them and I wasn't very good at the
start you know when I think about my
original um classes that I I taught but
you get good after a while at reaching
Ordinary People and so for me that was
that was very helpful and I I kind of
think that um that's nice apprenticeship
that a lot of um academic philosophers
strive not to have but they they're
actually hurting themselves by not doing
that you do better when you have to
teach people who are a harder audience
and and one person I'll say too um
Alistair McIntyre when he was at Notre
Dame University he could have not taught
any classes at all or he could have just
taught graduate students and he
deliberately chose to teach
undergraduates and not to teach
philosophy classes but to teach these
service classes and I I really admired
him for for that and I asked him well
why did you do that he's like these are
the most important students you know
it's easy to teach philosophy students
teaching these other students this is
the one chance we have to reach them and
and get them to appreciate this this
field but I think that you know um there
could be a lot of ways in YouTube that
that somebody who has a different
temperament or different experiences
could teach philosophy well maybe if
they are more shy they they don't have
to be as theatrical right they they
don't have to I'm I'm an outgoing person
so that's kind of natural to me but
there's some people who are more
introverted you know there's a there's a
woman who goes by the moniker Dr logic
um and she's got a whole bunch of really
great videos on on logic and I I instead
of shooting my own I refer people to
hers because I don't want to do that
work and she's doing it and she's not as
you know she's not as animated and all
that but she does really good good work
so I think there could be like a whole
multiplicity yeah I mean you do have to
know what you're talking about I think
people pretty quickly if you don't know
what you're talking about people are
going to figure that out pretty quick
right now um there was one there was one
other thing I wanted to respond to but I
I can't quite recall what it was because
you had such a lot a lot of good good
points in there um maybe it'll come back
to me uh over time let's let's give it a
chance to come back and then we'll come
back to Patricia but we have Ibraham and
Rick with their hands raised so let
let's go to Ibraham hello ibraim how are
you please jump in
and thank you thank you very much I am
glad to have you
here gregori I am a philosopher from
istan turkey and I began to teach uh
philosophical counseling when I read the
lose book in Turkish
no he's going to his other works is also
translated I also translated some of
hiss into Turkish is going to be
published and r i just when I you know
look at your I know your YouTube and I
said oh my gosh the classical
philosophers if they s they see this
they will be jealous of Gregory you know
some of them they don't have a chance
you know to to rich people and they just
postly they they become famous you know
I just wonder what is the major problems
and cases people ask to you and second
because you know through the internet
and social media because I am also
following you you reach a lot of people
and I am also I am just started in
Turkish but I am I am just you know
surprised when I saw Turks in Europe
from Europe to Australia they they they
they they teach me they reach me they
they ask questions I never imagined this
so there's are so many people they they
they have problems and they they don't
want to to talk psychologist but uh this
the Outreach of your your your viewers
you know I just wonder this and also I I
agree with you as Sam Harris and a guy
who read Richard Dawkins books he just
has an existential problem and he was at
the verge of the suicide because if he
his said if everything is meaningless
and everything is is chaotic Etc there
is no point in the life then I I suggest
him I introduced him to uh Dr Victor
Frank for meaning yeah yeah yes I also
want to hear from you on this things
thank you oh thank you um yeah I mean
it's it's it's uh striking um the range
of people
that have have problems that you know
maybe a psychologist can help them with
but um maybe sometimes the psychologist
want to take an approach that isn't all
that helpful for them and then you know
we have resources within the vast field
of philosophy I mean we've got like you
know 2500 years of stuff to draw on in
just in the west that that we can mine
for insights um we we're so lucky with
that and um you know we can direct
people to to what's helpful and my my
clientele has been kind of a mixed bag
you know I've done some Executive
coaching um you know with SE Suite
Executives and very often they know
exactly what they want to work on but
sometimes they've um you know they're
they're actually wrong about that as we
find out talking about things down to
like people who are just um you know
working in a grocery store and they're
having trouble with anger management
they're fighting with their spouse or um
you know blowing up at people at work
and they want to do some techniques um
so it's it's it's a it's a wide spectrum
I like Franco and actually I was as you
were talking about um the problem of
meaninglessness another person I was
thinking of who I did some videos on
recently is Marcus Aurelius um who you
know officially he's a stoic right so
he's got a party line you could say but
he says at like four or five different
places in the meditations you know it
could could be stoic Providence which I
believe could be epicurian Adams in
which case it's all just kind of random
nonsense you know um there's no
Providence uh that none of that keeps me
from living a good life and and being a
good person and I love that because we
have you know in the modern stoic
movement very broadly speaking there are
the people who call themselves
traditional stoics and they think the
other modern stoics are a bunch of
Heretics because they've taken you know
the logos and Providence and all that
out of the picture so they're not really
stoics they're just exploiting it um and
you know when when one of the main stoic
says hey even if none of this stuff is
true I can still use these these
techniques these these insights to quit
being such a jerk to people and to have
a harmonious life even though I've got
this incredible responsibility on my
shoulders that's that's a good model for
us you know Franco I mean way way worse
circumstances right so um yeah that's
that's uh that's that's quite cool and I
I'm happy to hear that you you've been
translating Works into
Turkish
um you know that's we live in this this
now incredibly
connected world where English has become
a lingua franka but it is like super
super important that important things
get translated back and forth you know
um I mean we're fortunate in that
there's plenty of translation out of
other languages into English or maybe
not as much as we'd like but to for
people a language is like a home for
people right so to have works in your
native language is so important for
people to be able to um relate to them
you know and doing good translation you
know as I I'm a translator myself and
I've become very gentle with other
translators because I realize that my
own translations far from perfect you
know what do you translate from uh Which
languages do you translate from Gregory
mostly Latin and and French occasionally
German when I when I write on Aristotle
or epicus I'm TR I'm providing my own
translations from from Greek as well but
most of my published translations have
been from French or Latin and where did
you pick up French well my mother's
family is French Canadian uh although
although my mother grew up in Chicago
and so she was she was
frankophone and grew up in a in a little
part of Chicago which was all French
Canadians and monomane Indians she was a
fourth generation American but she grew
up you know not learning English until
she was five and so my generation I was
one of the few kids in my generation who
actually learned some half-ass French
and um then she made me take French
Classes when I was in eighth grade and
10th grade and I screwed off because I
could afford to and then when I was in
college um they put me my first year
they were trying this new program and if
you were in the language houses you
would get a a a single room you didn't
have to have a roommate so they're like
you speak French right and I was like
yeah I guess so so they put you in they
had a German house a French house
Spanish house and a Japanese house and
the idea behind it it was an
experimental thing there would be a
native speaker living in one of the
rooms and you would do cultural things
with them and chat you know in the in
the the language so the other people who
were in there one was a m guy who spoke
French um you know and then the other
was a guy who was supposed to be
learning French who didn't actually
learn a lick of French and we would chat
back and forth and she she liked me so
she would she would buy us you know beer
and and liquor when we were underage
and we had a great time together you
know and then we were supposed to be
studying French together but we didn't
uh we just kind of bsed around and then
when I finished college and I was like
working in a gas station for a while
before I took the security job um I I
had this this textbook and it was a
textbook that was a French textbook in
French and I was like maybe I should
buckle down and actually learn decent
French so so I did and then you know you
do your learning your grammar and your
Vo vocabulary and then you start reading
people and translating and all that so I
was you know reading about air sart and
people like that and I could talk with
my mom and actually this is totally off
topic but my mom was a super super
outgoing person she unfortunately died
when she was my current age 53 um so she
she had a great but short life and she
loved to talk smack about people and so
we would walk around and like you know
the place that we live live right now is
above what used to be the Grand Avenue
Mall and
so she would walk with me and she'd be
like you know G gr there you know talk
look at that look at that fat lady there
you know or check out that guy over
there how terribly he's dressed and
nobody could understand what she was
saying not even French speakers because
Canadian French is different than
Parisian French you know and so it was
like a code that she would use and that
was part of my practice you know and and
so you know when I and actually I'll say
one other thing and this will show you
how silly my my career has been I got
caught up in uh Keva nationalism in the
90s and so studying French philosophy at
Southern Illinois University was a way
to stick it to those anglos you know um
and and uh you know uh so I was you know
studying people like dared D Maurice
blondel or you know Maurice Mar Ponte
and reading them in French and it was
partly to you know was young I was kind
of kind of stupid at the time
emotionally it was a way to like say you
know this this part of the world used to
be New
France technically it was you know um
this is all occupied territory you know
being being French Canadian is more like
being uh Latino or something you know
which it isn't um I mean up in Canada it
is but it's not here in the United
States and uh I got really you know
worked up about the 95 referendum you
know um and then afterwards I realized
just how silly I was being about all of
this stuff you know well I'm really glad
I'm really glad first of all Ibrahim has
has ducked out of here but thank you
Professor oir for Charming in and for
precipitating this thread for those of
you who don't know him ibraim is very
distinguished professor in turkey and is
here at Clark on a on a you know yeah
he's a visiting fellow in the US and I
think may have another year so he's also
apaa certified and is a true Pioneer
there's a method to his Madness because
he's translating seminal Works into
Turkish in order to disseminate the the
the practice of philosophy in Turkey
more widely as well so uh you're doing a
great job of being a Pioneer and we're
really very grateful to you because
turkey is such an important country you
know on the hinge of Europe and Asia
yeah so as well as probably in some ways
the most modern of the Islamic nations
in many respects the most secularized so
we we really salute you ibraim and thank
you so much for all of your
work yeah you you know just not on
Turkey there are lot of students from uh
you know or uh almost 300,000 students
Internationals in turkey and I just find
out you know many many of them they are
also taking translation back to their
country so just like Gregor has 14
million viewers you know you can't you
can't you you can't imagine the impact
of anything you you humbly done okay I
am trying my best you also Pier had is
also is very you know is very well known
in Turkey maybe you can say something as
a a you know you have in France about
Pier yeah thank you okay well thank you
very much again Abraham is great to see
you um we'll see turkey is is is is new
to philosophical practice relatively
speaking and vice versa I mean in terms
of its modern Incarnation so we'll see
how it goes but uh I I have three books
coming out in chish simultaneous
February so I will speak with you more
Ibrahim about that and maybe we can
arrange something go back to Istanbul
and and do some kind of a book launch
but we'll talk about that a bit later
okay just just let me remind you last
last week on
the 26 of November we have a panel
discussion at the University in Turkey
they just asked me that to summarize
what is going on in here in North
America and also Canada I have
summarized all of your works and also
about apaa what is apaa is doing and
there was a big interest in in in this
and it is also publicized on the
websites of the University yeah I just
want to share with you well again thank
you so much for your for your pioneering
work and I'm sure it's very impactful
you're being modest but when you already
have a large influence in in in the
educational World in Turkey so whatever
you take on is going to be attended uh
by people so again thank you it's great
to see this moving into this part of the
world it's very important I think
philosophical practice will do a lot of
good not only in Turkey but also in
neighboring countries so thanks again
Abraham for all your hard work and we'll
talk more okay as as new things come to
the Forefront I just wanted to say
before we get to Rick who's very patient
thank you Rick I'll I'll come to you
momentarily I promise we still have
loads of time but uh I don't know
Gregory if we if we mentioned this last
time you're telling me your mother was
French Canadian I grew up in French
Canada oh I guess you didn't know this
you did my father's first language was
French okay my first language is English
I'm fluently as my mother was fond of
saying fluently belligerent in both
tongues and uh um but I mean you're so
right French Canadian was divorced you
know when my dad was in Europe during
World War II he served with the Canadian
Armed Forces of course and he spoke
French in France he spoke perfect KCA
French and they said to him uh in
French you're speaking 18th century
French it was was Charming for them for
about 10 minutes you know my mom got
called pean peasant in in Paris and she
did not like that at all no but she has
the advantage in Paris of being also to
be able to be unintelligible in French
if she wanted to Trash Talk the
parisians they wouldn't understand her
either that's true yeah slang you know
she could speak Z to them and and they
wouldn't understand a word they were cut
off from France after
1763 basically when England won they
allowed the Quebec you know to maintain
its Catholic religion and its French
language and it was you know the British
had a democratic attitude and they said
well we let them keep their religion and
their culture under British sovereignty
so there's this constant constant
friction between the British and the
French do not tend to get along very
well at the best of times you know but
but but the language was really kind of
cut off from France and so it's very
colorful they taught us isian French in
school it was useless in Quebec and then
vice versa when you go to France you you
better speak proper French so very
interesting what part of Quebec was she
from do you know my mom she wasn't she
she she was a fourth generation American
so they know where they're probably
power oh yeah yeah so so what ended up
happening is my great great-grandfather
fought in the American Civil War so he
crossed the border into Vermont took a
doctor's son's place for 500 bucks which
was a lot of money at that time
and then you know he survived the Civil
War and they they lived in the Northeast
for a long time and they would just keep
bringing um people down from Quebec sort
of like how you know immigrant
communities do today and so um my
great-grandfather and
great-grandmother moved the family to
Chicago in the
1930s and um they they had a bunch of
kids they all lived in like the same
little little District uh it was called
the San Jean Baptist District after the
the church there and it was all French
Canadians and monoman Indians because
there's more monomon in Chicago than
there are in the reservation and they
speak French and
um they you know like my grandfather's
generation so he married um a Ubi from
from Quebec City and actually he his
brother married her sister too and they
all lived together in the same block and
so what they would do is they'd keep
bringing in people right so there's this
constant influx of French speakers until
my mom's generation and then then they
were kind of established but that entire
generation they all spoke French as
their first language and so you know um
I I grew up hearing it all the time and
picking up not just you know the good
words but also the swear words too um
some of the earliest words were like
kalas and tabernac and you know imis
things like that for my uncles and um so
you know it's kind of a weird thing is
she what you know she she's an immigrant
but she's not an immigrant because she's
a fourth generation but her mom was you
know from Quebec and and all that so
it's very confusing to fastic you know
and New England is riddled with we call
them Maine the state of Maine all kinds
of people are descended from cuqua
French people and they are Americans
several Generations now and they lost
French but still have French names yes
yeah so well and that's and that's the
way most of the people in my family are
so Sadler is my dad's family name and
it's not the real family name it was
originally skua but my grandfather
changed it my mother's family name is l
and we're the lemes with the missing s
because when my great great-grandfather
came over he was illiterate didn't know
how to spell his name so they they
registered him as l m r i e and so
there's all these
lrees who don't speak French and funnily
enough uh there's a big branch of the
family that has a lot of Native American
in it so they're kind of swy and and all
that they just tell everybody they're
Mexican because it's easier to tell
people that than to try to explain what
kabak qua means and all that so yeah I
actually had I had an Iranian friend as
well who would just tell people he was
Mexican because trying to explain to
ordinary Americans what Iran
means that he wasn't really Iranian he
was more aani and his family it was just
too complicated you know yeah yeah
Mexico covers a lot of ground so to
speak yeah yeah
okay thank you for that Rick thanks for
your patience please go ahead un mute
nice to see you can you hear me I
can okay great so first a comment Greg
uh and then question that I often ask
people here on the uh Agora the comment
is how ironic is it that uh
neuroscientists are sending people to
philosophical counselors with
existential crisis people like Sam
Harris or or Dawkins for instance so
scientists in general no matter what I
have had three clients that have come to
me
specifically because Sam Harris gave
them this kind of uh you know where they
thought their life was meaningless and
all that yeah yeah so we can thank them
for generating business for us but uh
that's kind of funny but it's kind of
sad that it's ironic and said that our
alleged you know scientific voices are
you know sort of destroying people's
mental health yeah and and we the ones
who have to pick them up and try to put
them back on track um so I just wanted
to share that with you but the question
is um so there's a kind of debate within
philosophical counseling I'm not sure if
you've ever ever been pulled into it but
about method list methods and what's
your primary method as a philosophical
counsel or or just like my question to
you is what's your philosophical toolkit
generally consist of and do you have
position on that method no method kind
of question yeah I
mean certainly we use a lot of ideas
that we we take from the thinkers who we
like the most so I I draw heavily on
various traditions of virtue ethics
coming from ancient and medieval
philosophy and existentialist philosophy
and you know some other things here and
there um but then you know is there like
a general method not really because I'm
an Eclectic when it comes down to it so
a client you know if they're receptive
to
bibliotherapy I'll say well let's let's
actually read you know this and talk
about this right but maybe maybe they're
not maybe they just want can you give me
some practices to work on and and I'll
I'll do that and
um you know Lou mentioned dialogue
earlier I I see dialogue itself as an
integral part of it you you talk to
somebody rather than just um the the
client laying out their problems and
then you putting it okay you've you've
checked this thing off here's this
technique you know instead we got to
talk we gotta like dig into what their
what their situation is and what
insights we can draw out and and that's
kind of unpredictable I've I've found
and I'd be interested to hear from
others I don't know that I've
actually got something that I would call
a method
because you know to me that implies a
little bit more consistency than I think
I actually display in in my
practice um which you know might not be
a good thing you know frankly it might
be better if I could like say here is
exactly what we're going to do but and
then clients will sometimes ask me okay
what are we what are we going to do I'll
be like well I know what works for you
so it's it's a little bit more pragmatic
um but I'd be curious I mean do you have
a method that you would say like this is
this is I can write it down for you
here's what we actually do in this or or
anybody I'm I'm pretty much like you um
I'm on the no method and all methods and
whatever seems appropriate kind of
approach
yeah I mean I'm not like I I want to
reject method or anything I just don't
have it available right to my my
attitude is um since the problems that
come to us if you made an analogy with
them you know one tool doesn't work for
all problems right right if everybody if
you all you have is a hammer you're G to
treat everybody like a nail yeah so the
people that come to us are they exhibit
all sorts of different kinds of things
so what might be appropriate to come out
of us having access to a whole variety
of tools approaches Etc and I think
you're right that one thing that we all
probably should emphasize is the process
of the D yeah so if that if you want to
call it a method but even that I mean
sometimes different things happen in
sessions so like you said you know they
might want to learn a certain practice
and so now you are a tutor or whatever
accountability partner yeah
yeah what about does anybody else like
is there anybody here who can say yeah I
definitely have a method here's exactly
what it is no sure if Pier if Pier were
here um then he would definitely say
that he has philosophical Midwifery
because he's the know greatest exponent
of it and it's definitely a method and
it applies to a huge range you know
possible cases so there are people who
have uh who have methodologies that they
really prefer to work with um but I
think I'm also in Rick's Camp uh and
your camp in that in that it's a dance
you know the dialogue is a dance and you
never know what the dance is going to
look like till the dance till your
partner shows up and you start dancing
and then you and then you kind of work
it out and it might be a kind of dance
that no one's ever danced before usually
it is one way or another so we have
favorite philosophers I think that would
be I'd be on safer ground to ask you you
know who are your five most frequently
cited philosophers if you're going to
cite anyone and I know Rick has his
favorites and we all do Patricia puts in
the chat room that she thinks you're
wise to let method grow out of the
experience so um you got a compliment
there from a very experienced
practitioner and that's that's a good
thing we have about three minutes we
generally wrap up at 5:30 and uh that's
three minutes away would anyone who has
not spoken like to like to ask the the
last question of the day to Greg is
anyone out there um wanting to ask or
say something if so now's your
opportunity please please don't be shy
not everyone at once but hello to
everybody just a thank thank you thank
you for this lovely conversation and and
sharing I really appreciate it you're
welcome youo Stefania I mean it's
getting we you and Patricia in ity where
what time is it in Italy now must be
getting uh late in the day it's 11 30
p.m. well thank thank you for being here
I mean that is that is quite a
commitment on a Saturday night you
know well Italy is a very important
country for philosophical practice I
want to tell you in case you didn't know
that's a it's a it's a very big deal
there are many many practitioners many
schools a lot of conferences a lot of
literature we're all going to be there
this summer uh Stefania in Rome for the
World Congress and uh in August and
we'll we'll keep in touch with you but
we'll definitely get together for real I
mean how else are we going to eat
Italian food if we're you know not in
Italy and and and drink some real coffee
so I'm looking forward to that uh but
thank you very much for joining us at
this hour and hope to to see you again
um the next the next Agora we're going
to not have one that you know New Year's
Eve or New Year's day it will be a
little bit later in January and the
guest is a surprise that's because it's
not scheduled yet but I have some really
some really great practitioners to
follow from our first year of doing this
we've had tremendous success in terms of
the quality of our guests of course and
they get a lot of views not yet 14
million Greg on the AA Channel but we're
getting we're getting a lot of views and
uh and we're attracting new uh
participants into the audience and into
our program so it is having a modest
success I think it's a wonderful thing
uh for us to get to know each other and
also to ultimately to get this up on the
web so that people can get to meet the
more personal side of the practitioners
who are out there and maybe gravitate
toward them you know as they discover
that that they're interesting people
which you certainly are so
congratulations on all your success and
I hope it carries forward for you I'm
sure it will thanks yeah yeah thanks for
having me on this is very enjoyable and
uh this is the first one that I've been
able to get to CU usually I've got like
different things going on in Saturdays
but I'm definitely going to be there for
later ones because this is this is a a
great format well great it's totally
informal every every guest is always
worried and they send what do I have to
prepare and when I tell them nothing n
yente just show up and we'll have a
conversation for a change you know we
don't we don't need to be academics for
each other we can we can be a little
more real and just talk about ourselves
and our experience and share with others
you know the way that we pract practice
I think that's a very valuable thing in
addition to the more formal literature
that we that we spawn so thank you very
much Greg let's give a can we can we get
make some kind of a round of applause at
least virtually everyone's
clapping